foi um bom dia
faria mais à vontade se estivesse numa
sala de aula mas estar aqui com vocês
reproduzo certa forma um momento
importante de interação primeiro diria
que contrariando as teses de que estão
borrados as fronteiras
as diferenças de tempo espaço e comércio
justamente fito andando entre os anos
2000 e tantos para trás dos anos 50 anos
é uma trajetória longa é uma trajetória
que é que ainda está ocorrendo é uma
história que ainda está se inscrevendo
as histórias que a gente vive a gente
compartilha não porque elas sejam
exemplares especiais
as histórias nossas histórias são muito
parecidas
entretanto o ato de compartilhar um ato
de rememorar e é trazer ao vivo trazer à
tona uma história que se inscreve num
grande painel da humanidade da nossa
humanidade toda a nossa vida tudo que
nós fizemos sentimos pensamos se
inscreve nesse painel
penso que recordei dois pontos que são
relevantes na minha vida não são os
únicos nem os mais importantes mas são
muito importantes uma formação
profissional
uma não escolha profissional
paradoxalmente quando se fala tanto da
importância de escolher a profissão e
por outro lado uma condição
a condição de mulher e aí esta baliza de
tempo é importante né
entre os anos 50 e tantos e usa nos 2010
é preciso resgatar um pouco da origem
porque veja nossa vida não é um plano
formal organizado que a gente cumpra à
risca a decisões a imprevistos a
contingências as circunstâncias
nessa trajetória que a gente corre
essa é a riqueza da vida na sua
sonoridade seu movimento então retomar
minhas origens apenas para dizer que era
eu uma mocinha então né
uma menina numa família de nível médio
que tinha de third atípico de ter um pai
padre depois delegado de polícia e não
tanto estranho né e uma mãe
tipicamente à tona de casa e uma família
estruturada dedicada de de muito rigor
com muitos princípios e com muita
certeza
que bom que ao longo da minha vida eu
aprendi a relativiza los
que bom de qualquer modo se sabia o
caminho dos meninos
esse cabelo sabe o caminho das meninas e
os meninos estudavam porque tinha que
trabalhar
o provedor pai era substituído pelo
provedor marido
os homens sempre tiveram historicamente
uma carga muito pesada
as meninas sim as meninas dessas
famílias tinham que estudar porque elas
podiam precisar trabalhar ela não deviam
trabalhar e o caminho era o curso normal
a formação da professora primária que
aproximava as crianças que nós teríamos
como mulheres da família das crianças
que vinham ao grupo escolar ou curso
primário e que fazia uma ponte muito
natural entre a nossa casa ea escola
esse é o nosso caminho não precisaria
trabalhar mas se precisar se trabalharia
hora estranhamente ou
até com certa normalidade os países
faleciam cedo aos 16 anos eu fiquei
órfão de pai e aí eu fui trabalhar antes
de me casar então cumprir uma profecia
cumprida se uma das grandes sabedoria da
época né
o interessante é que essa escolha não
escolha profissional
ela se deu bem comigo eu podia ter
abandonado esse caminho mas eu sempre me
senti muito feliz muito à vontade nessa
interação nesse espaço de interação que
é sempre novo que não se repete que tem
extrema criatividade extrema liberdade
com todas as restrições que essa palavra
trás ea possibilidade de nunca repetir
ipsis literis a mesma realidade e
crescer junto à porque hoje se fala
muito e fazer junto e crescer junto hora
estar com as pessoas estarão os alunos é
estar fazendo junto interagindo tocando
veja eu não tenho uma visão edulcorada e
romântica da profissão
sabemos todos nós quanto nos custa o
desgaste emocional investimento
intelectual mas é um momento único inpe
então vejam uma não escolha que deu
certo
pode ser uma forma que tá aqueles que
por ventura tenham que seguir um caminho
que não foi exatamente da sua escolha
embora hoje os jovens estejam muito
livres para fazer essas escolhas
um ponto importante nessa transição do
meu relato é a a questão da transgressão
eu não falaria em pequenas grande está
transgressões tem que habilitar o nosso
espírito o espírito de rebeldia um
espírito de de transgressão porque caso
contrário não nos movemos nós não avança
a sociedade não avança conhecimento ea
nossa vida como se fosse possível para
claro que eu não vou falar e pequenas ou
grandes transgressões porque o
importante é um espírito nas versões a
claro que a nossa moralidade a nossa
ética tinha da nossa educação baliza
indicando quando a transmissão é
predadora e quando ela constrói alguma
coisa mas tem essa inquietação como
quiserem chamar
é fundamental não pode haver uma paz de
espírito completo na placidez é é
preciso querer é preciso querer
transformar bom aí então eu faço uma
passagem pra uma mulher que não quis
ficar só normalista éramos lindas até
hoje se canta jornalistas com as suas
rainhas pegada né
com a sua juventude a passeando na rua
da praia ou pelas ruas da cidade
mas as mulheres começaram a querer outra
coisa e isso não vou entendido que
querem as mulheres que mais elas querem
que ela já não têm como pode os jovens
terem intenções e desejos se elas têm
tudo o que precisam temos afeto familiar
e sua realização como mulher mas não as
mulheres queriam mais e aí começa uma
uma ruptura no estado de aceitação da
menina normalista para uma pessoa que
quer avançar e que sobretudo encontra na
época a ausência de meios de transporte
ausência de comunicação uma cidade do
interior era preciso sair dell de lá
para estudar e aí a primeira surpresa do
marido
que coisa estranha tem uma coisa
acontecendo porque entendo bem que
conhecimento sempre causou medo causa
medo até hoje
o conhecimento é libertador e o
conhecimento assusta
então que que estamos que estão querendo
as mulheres querendo estudar onde vão
saindo de casa deixando seus filhos ou
cumprindo todas as tarefas
é que no 01 destinada e queriam sair
sair para estudar a cidade então padre
em imaginem estrela e as pessoas assim
entre as frestas da janela com o olho
muito grande observando onde vai uma mãe
de família estudar pra que querem as
mulheres é a grande pergunta por que não
cumprem apenas o seu papel e essa foi a
luta das mulheres a há muitas mulheres
que precisariam ter um grande painel de
reconhecimento porque tudo que se vive
hoje nos anos 2000 e libertar de opções
de escolha
foi um dia de grande dificuldade
muitas mulheres perderam destruíram suas
casas perderam seus maridos incomodar os
seus filhos criaram todo tipo de impasse
a luta das mulheres não foi simples e
não é
e vejam que eu não falo dessa luta que
tem do outro lado um inimigo ou seja o
homem ou que tenha outro lado o modelo a
ser seguido
falo de mulheres que tinham um desejo de
estudar uma trajetória para cumprir e
que faziam isso sem declarar que era
preciso ter um opositor
quando eu vou lutar de seguir a
trajetória de formação e aí chega o
exercício profissional
aí começa uma história que que sair das
crianças os pequenos 78 anos até até os
homens maduros as mulheres naturas
passando pelos adolescentes passando
pelos jovens adultos e pelos adultos
adultos
a maior surpresa a maior alegria a maior
descoberta foram as crianças na sua
simplicidade na sua espontaneidade
naqueles olhares meigos e curiosos e o
processo de alfabetização exatamente
mágico o modo como as crianças
trabalhadas em sala de aula onde a lei
depois dos adolescentes os adolescentes
a que pode parecer a alguns trabalhosos
eles são ricos e dores ricos de
hormônios plenos de hormônios e plenos
de rebeldia e muito ansiosas para que
alguém lhes fale entre a gramática
metáfora e os números que ele fale
alguma coisa da vida
ansiosas que estão para vivê-la ansiosos
que estão para chegar aos 18 para
ficarem grandes e para serem autônomos e
sempre atentos
aquilo que diz respeito à vida além
claro das figuras e da matemática
bom depois então a havia um estágio
intermediário os meninos faziam um eram
contadores as meninas jornalistas nos
meninos trabalhavam ninguém discutia
tenho que trabalhar mas há alguns os
demais posses e uma faculdade em porto
alegre significava engenharias e teatro
é fácil científico letras e humanidades
faz o clássico então havia uma divisão
eu não diria uma divisão ruim di castro
eu deveria dirigir uma contingência um
estar no mundo uma condição de mundo que
também não nos impediu nós as
normalistas de crescermos eu também
podia ter ido embora da profissão
poderia ter ido fazer outra coisa e por
fim então eu chego à faculdade e aí
começa a essa é uma outra etapa em que
eu junto com as pessoas e na formação de
pessoas que fariam alguma coisa ou no
campo profissional de mercado ou no
campo profissional do magistério
tive a o privilégio de começar meu
trabalho estamos já a gente me esqueci
de dizer nos anos 70
tive o privilégio de ser uma das
fundadoras da fax atual univates que
lava jato na desenvolvemos o ensino
superior lá uma universidade comunitária
tive
trema honra de integrar a universidade
federal do rio grande do sul de que
muito me orgulho orgulho de todos os
granéis
depois tive de forma inesperada a grande
oportunidade de chegar a são leopoldo a
unisinos e em cada etapa de de se fazer
aquilo para o qual eu me formei os
estudos que fiz resultaram em
compartilhamento em construção de
conhecimento em crescimento também sobre
tudo mas muito meus alunos a todos nós
juntos eu diria assim se eu tivesse que
fazer um libel libelo a luta das
mulheres
internamente as gotas volta de lisboa a
um libelo ao magistério pela grandeza da
sua missão e um libelo a unisinos pelas
oportunidades que oferece
enfim um grande tributo público aos meus
alunos
não posso me emocionar de todos os
tempos e de todas as clientes
obrigado